اسرائيل تعني التهجير منذ ان قامت عام 48
دمرت اكثر من 500 قريه فلسطينيه هدمت اكثر
من 170,000 منزل ولا حاجه او حجه لقوانين
او مبررات تمريرات مختلفه للحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه لعمليات الهدف
بالاضافه الى معاقبه المنفذي العمليات
وذويهم اسرائيل اي منازل او منشات في
المناطق التي تصنفها عسكريه لكن العدد
الاكبر من عمليات الهدم ينفذ تحت ذريعه
البناء دون ترخيص البناء دون ترخيص هو
ترجمه الاستراتيجيه تهجير الفلسطينيين من
المناطق المصنفه جيم في حسب اتفاق تلك
مناطق تشكل اكثر من 70% من مساحه الضفه
الغربيه ابرزها الاحياء الشرقيه لمدينه
القدس المحتله اكثر من 100 مبنى في القدس
الشرقيه هدمتها سلطات الاحتلال العام
الماضي وفق مكتب الامم المتحده فقد هدمت
سلطاته الاحتلال ايضا قرابه 4050 مبنا في
الضفه الغربيه
هذه الارقام هي امتداد للاستراتيجيه
الاسرائيليه المتوسطه نقل عن بنيامين
نتنياهو وهو في رئاسه الحكومه عام 2016
قوله ان البناء الفلسطينيه غير القانوني
مرض يجب التخلص منه تباهنتنياه حينها بان
حكومته هدمت الف منزل فلسطينيه في ذلك
العام اليوم ومع تشكيل حكومه تعتبر اكثر
تطرفا يبرز اسمه وزير الامن القومي ثمار
كبير يصدر الوزير الاسرائيلي الجديد
تعليماته للشرطه بهدم المنازل غير
القانونيه في القدس الشرقيه شرعت سلطات
الاحتلال في هدم 14 منزلا في اني واحد
مجزره حقيقيه يصفها الفلسطيني رغم ان
اتفاقيه جنيفر الرابعه تحضر على الاحتلال
تمهيد عمليات الهدم فان الفلسطينيين
يعتبرون الامر استراتيجيه ومنهجه لتهجير
الاف منهم في محيط المسجد الاقصى المبارك
سبعه الاف في فلسطينيه من حي وادي حلوه
والف و500 اخرين من حي الب الانمي بلده
سلوان والهدف اقامه ما يسمى الحوض
اليهوديه المقدس تمهيدا لهدم الاقصى
واقامه الهيكل المزعوب هذا مثال على
استراتيجيه الهدم الاسرائيليه في القدس
المحتله يحرق الامر المنظمات الدوليه لما
يشكله من خطر سياسيا بعيد المدى
جبل المكبر جنوبيه القدس اخر منزل هدمه
الاحتلال حتى ساعه اعدادي هذا التقرير
يمثل رقما يضاف الى قائمه المنازل المهدمه
لكنه لمن سكنوه اكثر من مجرد جدران